troisième titre à la une de l'actualité
aujourd'hui le parlement a finalement
adopté la réforme de l'enseignement
supérieur le sénat l'examinera en raison
de revenus avant de revin sur la
longueur du débat les manifestations qui
l'ont marqué voyons tout de suite ce qui
a été modifié par rapport au projet
initial principalement une réduction du
pourcentage des personnalités
extérieures dans les conseils
d'université et des précisions sur la
notion de concours dans certaines
spécialités
c'est quand il y en a bachelier peut
entrer en première année universitaire
sans aucune sélection mais désormais il
s'inscrit dans l'université de son choix
compte tenu des capacités d'accueil de
l'étude du diplôme de fin de 2e année
entre normalement en 3e année mentionne
donc les deux sélections sauf dans
quelques formations spécialisées qui
seront énumérés par décret
mois de personnalités extérieures dans
les conseils d'université la
participation est réduit de 10% au
profit les étudiants et des enseignants
les grandes écoles ne dépendant pas
actuellement du ministère de l'éducation
choisir eux ou maintenant être rattachés
au grand serveur à de l'enseignement
supérieur créé par la loi
du côté des étudiants de gauche même à
la coordination nationale contre la loi
savary chacun campe sur ses positions
pensons qu'il ya des évolutions qui sont
posées nous d'abord sur le problème de
la sélection car entre le fait qu'il y
avait un concours prévue entre le
premier et le deuxième site c'est-à-dire
une sélection au bout de deux ans
d'études ceux-ci été codifiée par
l'article 13 cet article en très grande
partie du film a même si le restaurant
petits problèmes sur lesquels nous
seront très largement attentif il y
avait une sélection qui pour nous était
antidémocratique parce que ça ne
permettait pas l'ensemble des étudiants
d'avoir une véritable qualification et
de masse on ouvrait largement premier
cycle fermé deuxième cycle aujourd'hui
l'assemblée nationale la majorité à
l'assemblée nationale a modifié cette
contradiction qu'il y avait dans la
réforme et nous semble symbole ief
coordination nationale pour faire votre
syndicat étudiant elle a rejeté des
débuts dans sa totalité ce n'est pas des
amendements acceptés par le gouvernement
s'est dit à l'aise en aval qui vont
améliorer ou changer fondamentalement de
ré le texte reste une mauvaise copie à
nous les mettons toujours aux héros il
n'est pas question pour nous d'accepter
peut-être davantage qui à seulement un
mois ou un peu plus comptez-vous faire
là qu'est la rentrée universitaire
permettra de repartir d'avoir une action
concrète sur le texte d'abord durant la
discussion au sénat
l'espéranto sénateurs feront un travail
important de maintenant si le
gouvernement
sur certaines parties du projet loi si
la commission mixte paritaire
sénat-assemblée ne donne pas
satisfaction sur le tech qui n'est pas
du tout interdit chez nous fassions des
matches à nation d'ampleur à la rentrée
en septembre comme ça use toujours en
septembre octobre comme ça eu lieu
récemment